my name is Robert Vargas I'm an artist
based here in downtown Los Angeles my
creative process is very organic
I love collaborating with creatives that
do something completely different than
what I do I'm really looking forward to
seeing what kind of food and drinks
Michael and Chantal have prepared for my
guard show and dinner party my name is
Michael Fiorelli I'm the chef and
partner of love and salt in Manhattan
Beach collaboration if someone is on the
same wavelength as you is that one of
the most satisfying things in the world
the thing I'm most looking forward to
about working with Chantal is the way
we'll be able to play off of each other
Chantal is very studied in what she does
so I've been able to compose dishes
around that
my name is Chantal cioppino and I'm the
beverage director for the social group
working with Michael is gonna be great
the one thing that stuck out the most
about his style and his type of work is
that simplicity in flavors is something
that he really pays attention to so I
really just want to be able to bring it
when Michael and I pretty much wear our
heart on our sleeves
this is a space I'm gonna have about
seven frames pieces up on this wall and
then I'm going to be painting live up on
this wall the pain is going to go about
the width of the spins now I'm literally
gonna pull up come right in and then
just pull someone from the car or a
couple of people from the crowd and
create on the fly that's great I can't
wait to see what my what my art tastes
like I love being able to build a
narrative off of the menu with telling a
narrative through Roberts life his
artwork and that's for me creating an
experience not only with the guests but
also with the people that I work with I
think that's probably the driving factor
in any in any art or any craft really
food cocktails painting you know that's
what I'm most looking forward to about
tomorrow night somebody's gonna take you
through my notes cool and I'll tell you
the kind of where my inspiration came
from he's gonna do a whole roasted
chicken fired by Roberts Native American
heritage just roast the chicken till
it's juicy beautifully roasted crispy
skin tear some bread and toasted an herb
garlic shallots thyme sage and then just
rest the chicken right on top of that
bread so as the chicken rests and comes
to the table with the chicken jus the
bread just soaks up all the natural
juices of that chicken so as you take
the chicken you take a little piece of
that bread I love that family styled
sort of dining experience it really
creates that sense of community and
family sorry I'm finding these beautiful
baby carrots and taking the tops it
would be discarded or thrown away and
turning it into the focal point of the
dish so get the carrots really simply
prepared and roasted and in the carrot
tops
adding basil parsley so really
herbaceous some roasted garlic preserved
lemon so citrusy tangy salty and then
using that to make a pesto and then to
add richness to the dish is whipping
ricotta cheese with sea salt and then
using that to you know spoon on the
plate
you know refined and luxurious the first
drink for the dinner was gonna be kind
of like a bastardized take on a Negroni
x' but instead of using Campari I was
gonna work with you about you know
figuring out what the spice components
we're gonna be in the carrot dish so
that we can complement that by infusing
it overnight and
Jermain it's gonna involve a little bit
of Bombay some of them infused
saint-germain and then also really
beautiful appetitive
that's all I'm so stoked about this
venue me too I'm really excited right
good thank you all for coming out to our
show the work that you see up here is
really about my dialogue with the city
and it's really a personal thing for me
these are like poems the highlight I
think for me was the last piece that I
did and both the Shinto and Michael gave
me part of the ingredients that they use
and I incorporated that and I think we
came away with a really amazing piece
thank you guys for your amazing amazing
just work tonight tell us what you're at
what you're doing right now well I just
finished hand carving some ice for you
guys and then I start molding it off
into what's gonna go into your first
drink so first drink that we had tonight
is actually named by Robert and we call
it the Vargas it's a cocktail that's
meant to open up the palate cleansing
get you guys ready for some food here
we've got the roasted baby carrots with
carrot top pesto and with ricotta cheese
this is a five green salad it's five
grains and fibers so the chicken we
talked about with the I call them torn
croutons inspired by Navajo flatbread
Chantal studied Robert so well so I've
learned a lot from her in the way that
I've been able to compose my dishes
plays a large part in what she's pointed
out to me about Roberts career in his
armor a true collaboration Cheers
the active collaborating is something
that I find a lot of people take for
granted I find that working with
different artists and chefs just really
teaches me a lot about myself and my
styles
what a great gallery go Robert filled it
and if you guys liked this episode make
sure to subscribe to you